[Music]
partial pressure of gases is the key
behind their exchange in the body this
is what we've learned so far but it's
the process as easy as it seems for us
from what we've studied so far the
process is simple
RBC's grab the oxygen that diffuses in
the bloodstream from alveoli and pass it
to the cells inversely carbon dioxide
gets in the RBC's to bind with the
hemoglobin and gets transported to the
lungs but trust me the processes are not
that simple any idea how the binding
takes place how do the molecules bind to
hemoglobin what happens after the
binding and what happens when the bonds
are broken to deliver the respective
molecules at the respective sites let's
answer all these queries in this video
let's begin with what happens in the
alveoli here the partial pressure of
oxygen is greater than that of carbon
dioxide does the carbon dioxide
molecules are made to leave the
hemoglobin and oxygen occupies the place
each oxygen binds to the iron component
that is the heme group of the hemoglobin
molecule thus a single hemoglobin can
usually carry four oxygen molecules the
binding of oxygen to hemoglobin helps in
the formation of a complex called the
oxyhemoglobin but this complex formation
is not very easy factors like
temperature hydrogen ion concentration
and also the concentration of carbon
dioxide molecules around influence the
binding of the oxygen along with this
there is one more factor that accounts
for the binding it's the structure of
the binding site we note that the
structure of a molecule changes as it
binds to any other atom or molecule so
here when the iron group binds to the
carbon dioxide the shape of the protein
changes reversibly now when the oxygen
is about to bind the change of shape has
to be reversed
so this is one more influential factor
for The Binding of oxygen after all the
factors approve oxygen molecules bind to
the iron group and form the complex of
oxyhemoglobin this is then taken to the
cells where the oxygen dissociates due
to increase in the partial pressure
compared to that in the cells the cells
on the other hand have a higher partial
pressure of carbon dioxide so now
imagine a scenario where the partial
pressure of oxygen is lower in cells and
higher in the RBC and at the same time
the partial pressure of carbon dioxide
is high in the cells and extremely less
in the RBC's it's obvious that the
oxygen molecules will dissociate and get
into the cells
does the oxyhemoglobin structure will
get disrupted and the hemoglobin protein
will again get altered now it's all set
to receive carbon dioxide molecules for
which it has equal affinity the binding
of carbon dioxide leads to the formation
of another complex named the carb amino
hemoglobin this is then carried to the
lungs where the partial pressure of
carbon dioxide is still lower and here
the scene is totally reversed now the
partial pressure of carbon dioxide is
higher than that of oxygen in the RBC's
in contrast to the cells as seen earlier
and the partial pressure of oxygen is
lower in the RBC's compared to the lungs
so the exchange and complex formation
takes place once again this is how the
gases are transported so are oxygen and
carbon dioxide always carried in the
form of these two complexes throughout
the body well not exactly
there is a lot more to know in this a
lot of oxygen approximately more than 95
percent is transported by the are PCs
the remaining amount is transported by
the plasma as oxygen dissolves in it
easily and the story of carbon dioxide
is totally different there is an
interesting twist here hardly 20 to 23
percent of
when dioxide is carried in the form of
carbon Meno hemoglobin hold on did I
just say around 23% only then what about
the remaining amount how is so much of
carbon dioxide transported then well
carbon dioxide is mainly transported
through the plasma this occurs in two
forms around 7% is carried as dissolved
solution in the plasma and the remaining
70% is carried in the form of
bicarbonate the conversion of carbon
dioxide into bicarbonate is carried out
by the enzyme carbonic anhydrase this
enzyme converts carbon dioxide and water
to give bicarbonate and hydrogen ions
and where does this happen the
conversion and the transport are all
carried out in the RBC itself that's
right the enzyme is present in the RBC
and converts the carbon dioxide and
water reversibly in bicarbonate and
hydrogen ions so the majority of the
carbon dioxide is transported in the
form of bicarbonate
but we do not exile bicarbonates so how
does the system work
how is carbon dioxide made available
during exhalation well the simple answer
is reconversion the bicarbonate and the
hydrogen ion produced are converted back
to carbon dioxide and water as the RBC's
reach the alveoli this is performed by
the same enzyme carbonic anhydrase in a
nutshell majority of oxygen is
transported by binding to the hemoglobin
protein on the other hand carbon dioxide
is transported mostly in the form of
bicarbonate in the RBC's and the
remaining in the form of carbon we know
hemoglobin in the RBC and dissolved
carbon dioxide in the plasma this is how
transport of the two gases is carried
out now if we plot a graph of partial
pressure of oxygen against the percent
saturation of hemoglobin with oxygen
then a sigmoid curve is obtained
this is called the oxygen dissociation
curve and is this really very useful
well it has a significant role to play
in the study of several factors that
affect breathing but we will discuss
about this graph in detail in the higher
grades for now let's get back to
respiration and learn some more
interesting facts about it meet you in
the next video until then do subscribe
to our channel happy learning
you